مع رئيس فاغنر، لديك جايني
بريجوسيان الذي يُفترض الآن أنه مات في
حادث تحطم طائرة، يقول الكرملين إن فلاديمير بوتين لا
علاقة له بالحادث، لكن
القادة الغربيين ليسوا متأكدين تمامًا من أنه لن يحدث الكثير،
ولا يوجد دليل على أن
القيادة الروسية ربما أسقطت  طائرة
ولكن بروجسيان هي الأحدث من بين العديد من
الشخصيات التي تضررت بعد عبور
الرئيس الروسي في عام 2006،
عميل المخابرات الروسية السابق الذي تحول إلى ناقد لبوتين،
ألكسندر ليتفينينكو، أصيب بالمرض في المملكة المتحدة
وسرعان ما توفي، ووجد الأطباء أنه قد
تسمم بمادة مشعة
بينما نفى الكرملين تورطه.
توصل تحقيق إلى نتيجة مختلفة
مفادها أن جهاز المخابرات الروسي (
FSB) كان وراءها، وربما تمت الموافقة على عملية FSB
لقتل السيد ليبينينكو من
قبل السيد بتروشيف الذي كان
رئيسًا لجهاز FSB
وأيضًا من قبل الرئيس بوتين
في عام 2018، في نفس البلد، سم مختلف
هذه المرة روسي سابق.  تم تسميم العميل المزدوج
سيرغي سكريبال وابنته
بغاز الأعصاب نوفيتشوك،
بينما نفى الكرملين مرة أخرى
تورطه في الأمر، ولم يحاول إظهار ازدرائه للسكريبوف،
فهو ببساطة جاسوس وخائن
لوطنه، كما تعلمون، هناك شيء من هذا القبيل
خائن ل  وطن واحد هو واحد منهم
في عام 2020 نفس السم ولكن هذه المرة داخل
روسيا، سقط المعارض الروسي أليكسي نافالني
بمرض خطير على متن رحلة داخلية
تم إجلاؤه طبيًا إلى ألمانيا،
وسخر بوتين من المزاعم بأن الكرملين
قد يكون وراء التسمم،
فهذا لا يعني على الإطلاق ذلك  إنه بحاجة إلى
تسميمه، ومن يحتاجه على أي حال، إذا
أرادوا ذلك، فمن المحتمل أن
يتابعوا الأمر حتى النهاية، وقبل بضعة أيام فقط، ربما كان
جنرال
يقول أحد مراكز الأبحاث في واشنطن، ربما كان على علم بتفاصيل حول
قصر يُزعم أنه قيد الإنشاء
لفلاديمير بوتين والذي  ينفي الكرملين
وفاته في السجن بعد تشخيص إصابته بسرطان الدم بشكل غير متوقع،
ولم يعلق الكرملين على هذه القضية، ووصف
فلاديمير بوتين
وفاة يفغيني باغوسيان بأنها مأساة، وقال إنه
يثق تمامًا في أن التحقيق الروسي في
الحادث المفاجئ سوف يسلط الضوء على الحقيقة.